die FIFA hat jetzt über 10 Jahre Zeit zu
zeigen dass es ihnen auch wirklich ernst
ist mit den Ankündigungen der Sport wird
was Gutes bewirken für die Menschen was
Gutes bewirken jetzt ist da über zehn
Jahre nicht viel passiert ein paar
Reformen ja das muss man auf anerkennen
das ist sehr gut aber nicht weitreichend
genug so jetzt haben wir mit wir meine
ich die Kritiker oder die
Zivilgesellschaft die NGOs
FIFA und Katar ein Rettungsring
angeboten um die den Ruf noch zu retten
und zwar ist es die wirklich bescheidene
Forderung ein entschädigungsform oder
ein zahlungsfonds für die
Hinterbliebenen und diesen Rettungsring
haben jetzt die cataris
verachtend beiseite geschoben indem sie
gestern gesagt haben nee machen wir
nicht wir müssen doch gar nicht welche
alles gestorben ist was übrigens eine
Lüge ist dann ist alles ganz gut
dokumentiert in Katar wer da wann wie